the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie well watched the Mad King die
I remembered him laughing as your father
burned itself at justice is that where
you tell yourself annoying
you're a servants of justice
but you were avenging my father and you
shove you sword in Aerys Targaryen back
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight and Game Theory's video today I
want to focus on brain stark and Jaime
Lannister I have talked about both of
these characters and some of my other
videos because I believe Jaime
Lannister's fate could be intertwined
with brain stark but today I want to add
a completely new layer to my original
theory as we all know one of the big
moments that helped kick off the series
was when Jaime Lannister pushed bran
stark out of the window that is how the
very first episode ended and pretty much
ever since I created my channel I have
been saying I think that moment in time
could come full circle in one of the
very last episodes of the series in
season 1 episode 1 Jaime attempted to
kill brain stark but I believe Jaime
could put his life on the line to save
marine stark near the end no one would
have thought this was possible after
watching the first episode but given the
direction Jaime's story is heading in I
think it's very likely in my opinion if
you've seen some of my other videos
about these characters then you already
know this is what I believe but I say
all that to say this I also think brain
stark will actually do something big for
Jaime next season and I believe this was
already foreshadowed in previous seasons
what's interesting is Jaime doesn't even
know this is possible but Jaime has had
a stain on who he is as a character in
demand ever since the show began the
three-eyed Raven told bran he could not
change the past because of the ink was
dry a part of Jaime's past is literally
written in ink but brain can change that
when the ink is dry all you have to do
is rip out the page and write a new one
let me explain exactly what I mean by
that Jaime Lannister's reputation has
pretty much been based around three
things he is known for before jaime
lannister lost his sword hand he was
known for being one of the greatest
swordsman in the realm this was a big
part of Jaime's identity and this was
one of the reasons why he was always so
cocky and confident another thing Jaime
was known for was being in an incestuous
relationship with his own sister but the
biggest stain on Jaime's reputation is
him being known as the Kingslayer this
is what Jaime was mostly known for and
at times you could see that he would
even embrace this portrayal of a man
without honor who could not be trusted
because he killed the man he saw
Noth to protect there were times when
Jamie tried to deny murdering his King
in cold blood
but no one believed him however very
early on in the show we started getting
hints that maybe we haven't heard the
whole story maybe Jamie did have a good
reason to kill the Mad King Aerys
Targaryen what did the Mad King say when
you stabbed him in the back
I never asked did he call you a traitor
he plead for a reprieve he said the same
thing he'd been saying for hours this
was just a small clue that maybe there
is more to the story and you have to
admit that even in that moment it
appears Robert Baratheon might have even
believed what Jamie was saying because
he did look a bit troubled when Jamie
said burn them all
regardless of what Robert may have
thought just then and never ended up
changing the way people looked at Jamie
several more seasons had to pass before
we finally got Jamie's version of the
story Holmes wanted you to in my opinion
this was one of the greatest scenes in
the show Jamie was a broken man and what
he told Brienne completely changed to
their relationship and how most of us
all Jamie as a character the only
problem is Bryan is one of the very few
people who know the story and even if
Jamie did start telling other people
that story how many people would
actually believe him at this point
Jamie has always known the truth and
sometimes he would act like he didn't
care when people called him names but
deep down this was eating him alive
regardless of what happened that night
Jaime Lannister broke his vows mr. Jamie
Lannister
someone forgot to write down all your
great deeds but still time is there for
a forty-year-old
night with one hand how can you protect
me with that I used my left hand Analia
grace makes for more of a contest even
though we are heading into the final
season this is still the only thing
Jaime is known for in the eyes of the
realm Jaime was a member of the
Kingsguard ever since he was a teenager
and after all those years he still only
has one deed written down in the white
book the only thing it says about Jaime
is he killed the king he swore an oath
to protect Jaime does not want to accept
this and I can't blame him who would
want to be only known for something like
that
just look at the way Jaime slams of the
book shut after Joffrey insults him this
is also eating Jaime alive on the inside
he can't live with the fact that he only
has one page in the white book but he
knows he still has time to fill those
pages with something good we see this
again when Jamie gives bran the Valyrian
steel sword Oathkeeper so Jaime
Lannister knighted and named to the
Kingsguard in his 16th year at the sack
of King's Landing murdered his King
Aerys ii pardoned by Robert Baratheon
thereafter known as the Kingslayer it's
the duty of the Lord commands to fill
those pages
and there's still room left in mine as
you can see this makes the second time
jamie has to face of the fact that is
one page only talks of him killing the
Mad King but he plans on changing that
before he dies and I think he will if
you read all the books you will see that
this has an even bigger impact on Jamie
than it does in the show there are a few
other times where Jamie's either
thinking about this white book or he's
just staring at the pages wondering what
he can do about it what we don't see in
the show is after Jamie gives briam the
sword Oathkeeper he sits alone in the
room staring at the book that he starts
to make some additions to his pages and
it makes him look even more pathetic he
adds that he was defeated in the
whispering wood by the young Robb Stark
during the war of the five kings then he
puts he was held captive at Riverrun and
ransomed for a promise that went
unfulfilled then he adds he was captured
again by the brave companions and maimed
at the word of Vargo hOAT their captain
he was then returned safely to King's
Landing by Brienne the maid of Tarth
so now after these additions it says
Jaime killed his king he was defeated
and captured by a boy in the field and
held captive at Riverrun for roughly a
year's time Catelyn then sets him free
on the promise that Jaime will safely
return her daughters which is something
he never does then he loses his sword
hand can you imagine what this must feel
like as if this book hasn't already
haunted him enough in my opinion there
is no way in hell Jaime dies without
getting some Redemption and this is
where bran stark comes into play these
two characters are destined to meet each
other again
Jaime is already heading his way so it's
only a matter of time before this
happens and I happen to think we will
see this pretty early next season when
they do see each other again this will
be a very big moment for both of them
Jaime will have to confront his past and
bran will finally be able to confront
the man who tried to kill him now as
I've said before I don't think bran
wants Jaime to be killed for this by now
I'm sure brain understands that becoming
the new three-eyed Raven was his destiny
so I don't see Jaime being punished by
bran however I'm sure everyone else in
the north will have something to say
about it not only that but they will
bring up other events from his past like
that time he killed his king every
still sees Jamie as the Kingslayer
except for a Brienne and his brother
Tyrion but that's not enough
Brienne has already been accused of
being in love with Jamie so of course
she would take his side she's been
carrying around a Lannister sword after
all so even though Brian is seen as an
honorable woman they won't just
automatically assume she's right about
Jaime there is really only one way Jaime
can have this stain removed from his
reputation and taken out of the history
books bran stark has already seen what
happened between Jamie and the Mad King
when bran and Mara were fleeing from the
three-eyed Ravens cave bran was
downloading this information and they
even shown it to all of us bran was
shown this for a reason and I think he
will actually help Jaime in the end he
saw Jaime stabbed the Mad King in the
back but he also heard the Mad King
screaming burn them all so he must know
that's what caused Jaime to act now
think about how everything has been
building up to this moment with Jaime
and bran
Jaime pushes him out of the window in
the first episode then in the third
episode Jamie tells Ned that when he
killed the Mad King it felt like justice
but Ned doesn't trust him later in the
same episode Jamie tells Robert what the
Mad King said right before he shoved
this sword in his back then in season 3
we hear the story in its entirety when
Jaime pours his heart out to Brienne
then Jamie tells Qyburn he saved half a
million people when he killed the Mad
King in season four Jeffrey marks Jaime
because he has no achievements written
down in the white book but Jaime says
that there is still time then a couple
episodes later Brienne reads the only
paragraph written on his page which is
when Jaime killed the king he swore to
protect then once again Jaime says there
is still time to fill the book with good
deeds right at the end of season seven
we find out there are now 1 million
people living in King's Landing and the
current queen has no problem with using
wildfire now in season 8 Jaime will have
one last chance to prove himself and
change the way history will remember him
bran will tell everyone what happened
the night Jaime killed the Mad King now
everyone should know it wasn't done in
cold blood then Jamie can pledge his
sword to House Stark he can help them
defeat the army of the Dead and if he
survives that battle he might be able to
save King's Landing one more time but
instead of saving half a million he can
save 1 million people after King's
Landing is destroyed in Cersei is dead
I think Brienne will find that white
book and make the necessary adjustments
to Jaime's pages even if Jaime dies in
the end he can die knowing that people
will not remember him only as of the
Kingslayer do any of you think bran
could help Jaime by telling everyone
what actually happened the night the Mad
King died will Jamie Lannister be
redeemed in the end put your thoughts or
questions down below I want to thank
everyone for watching the video and I
also want to thank all of my patreon
supporters I really appreciate your help
I hope everyone has a great day I'll see
you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]